it's time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour brought to
you every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which nor
what's company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope Larry Ellis sir
from the CBS television news staff and
Francis W carpenter of The Associated
Press
our distinguished guest for this evening
is Sir Percy spender ambassador from
Australia to the United States but so is
a pleasure to welcome back an old friend
my guest tonight is not only an old
friend of the Qantas coke program he's a
tried and true friend
of our country whenever we're in trouble
diplomatically speaking we can always
count on our friend from Australia to
pitch in when the going gets rough so
first I'd like to ask you something
about the recent conference in Manila do
we actually get what we wanted out of
that recent Southeast Asian pact depends
upon what you mean what you wanted I
think there was a very substantial
meetings of meeting of minds and having
regard to the difficulties which were
confronted with I think was a very
successful result well is this treaty
any good actually if India and the other
some other Southeast Asian nations stay
out of it well certainly we wouldn't
participated in it if we hadn't thought
it was good you must make a start
somewhere we know that other countries
have different views to our own we
understand the reasons why they differ
and that tapirs Australia's view that we
should go ahead and we did go ahead what
do you think the communism threat in
Southeast Asia is the next big threat is
that very the next pitch is to come from
Moscow i I can't say with any any degree
of certainty where the next step
pressure will be applied one knows very
well it's always applied where the
weakness is my feeling is and has been
for some time past that that trouble
will always occur in that part of the
world if any further trouble does occur
well Sir Percy a lot of people over in
this country
you think correctly or incorrectly that
the United States is again holding the
bag if I may say so on the Southeast
Asian Defense Alliance and that we are
committed to fight in defense of certain
countries but they are not committed to
fight unless they find that the action
is in their self-interest
now that true I don't think it is at all
sir
after all the under the terms of the
treaty we all enter into the exactly the
same obligation the degree of that
obligation in terms of burden of course
varies with countries depending upon
their military strength the economic
strength and their interest after all it
is quite clear that that this country
were they it's a greater economic and
military strength will carry the the
major portion of the burden of
maintaining peace in in that part of the
world but you will not find our own
country lacking in its desire to work at
all times in carrying out to the full
the obligations we've anything to
support support of all we're talking
about communist dangers and threats what
is the situation with the Communist
Party in your own Australia well I
suppose it's precisely the same as it is
in most democratic countries there has
been a communist party in our country
there have been more than one attempts
to deal with it by legislation but the
most effective means which so far have
been found to deal with it first by the
work of unionists themselves inside
their Union and secondly by what is
called at our country the secret ballot
for the election of union leaders and so
that where the secret ballot applies
communist leaders are not able to engage
in their usual tactics of rigging the
ballot I think you got a lot of applause
from Americans by the firm way that your
government handled at Petrov cased on it
have you learned yes the man who
deserted from communism have the
Russians reacted at all to your very
stern action in connection with this man
by giving him sanctuary the only the
only result is well known to the world
that I am able to speak about namely
that they were through there they were
through their embassy representatives
from Australia and we as a result did
likewise they have no relations with the
Soviet Union
and I understand the inspector he cannot
in strict protocol the relations are not
broken off but they just don't exist
they don't exist that's all the firstly
what about the situation in Japan now
the Russians are trying to draw a Japan
into their trade orbit would you
consider that a dangerous situation for
your country and for mine I do not doubt
whatever that the prime aim of Russia in
relation to Japan is at least the
neutralization of Japan but over and
above that its purpose is to seek by
whatever means are open to it by
blandishments my turn operations to
bring Japan into the orbit of the Soviet
and communist influence after all Stalin
said a long time ago that if that could
be accomplished in the belief of the
Soviet was after that the world the
Communist world would be invincible and
so that any attempt by Russia or by the
Communists to attract Japan into into
its orbit is one which causes concern
Larry to ask for to all the free world
whose purpose it ought to be to do
whatever it can to enable that Japan to
develop and be maintained as a
democratic country well Sir Percy does
Australia fear most the spread of
communism or is it afraid of a river
fired aggression by Japan last of all
times
we have been being wary of accepting the
proposition that the roots of democracy
have gone down deep into the Japanese
Way of life it's a very proper
observation to make that we see the
immediate problem in the foreseeable
future as that of communist aggression
what do you think about the rearmament
of Germany is at Bolling australians
very much Oh indeed it tears because
after all in two world wars we have that
we have come into into a state of war
and we've sent our troops overseas as a
result of incidents which took place a
long way from our shores in Europe and
so whatever takes place in Europe is of
consequence to us we believe in very
firmly that you cannot deal with
segments of the world except in terms
and seeing the whole problem globally
well sir Percy I'd like to turn to a
place it's a little nearer to your
country than Europe and that's Korea are
you withdrawing your troops in Korea the
way the we have and the British have
atleast a portion of them there have
been already it was announced only in
the last two three days these matters
were all discussed of course between the
different nations and that we have the
same as you withdrawing some of our
troops do you think that will create a
vacuum that will tempt the Communists to
try to come back down again I don't
think so you think they'll observe the
Armistice I do not think that where this
is my own judgment I do not think we're
likely to meet in Korea in the
foreseeable future any resumption of
overt aggression
I assume the person we're going to see
you sitting at the chair of Australia in
the coming General Assembly of the
United Nations opening next week and
there's a lot of interesting questions
there and one that everyone in the
United States is interested in is the
admission of Red China do you think it's
going to give us trouble at this coming
session I don't think any more than in
the past what do you think will happen
to it postpone it again
oh I would think that there isn't any
real danger of Communist China being
admitted into the netid nations at this
session should we say in the foreseeable
future is that a phrase as banded about
I thank you well true it is but of
course a it's a it's banded around like
so many other phrases but none of us can
see any more than a certain certain part
of the future and there is nothing
implement in life in respect of
everything one of the mystery question
is going to come up there Sir Percy is
the desire of Greece to incorporate
Cyprus within its Empire now may I ask
you are all the dominions going to back
the position of Great Britain and is
reluctant to turn over the island of
Cyprus to the Greeks I will do no more
than say that this is of course a matter
primary in which Great Britain is
interested but we too have our interests
for many other reasons from quite apart
from our very close association with
Great Britain well you've got another
case is close to home you've got the
Indonesians wanting to take over West
New Guinea
that's right and what are your views on
that well our views have been expressed
more than once we say in the first place
it isn't a matter which is a one which
ought to be brought into the night of
Nations for at all and secondly when the
issue is examined there isn't the
slightest merit in the claim of
Indonesia that they're making if these
people are West New Guinea are quite
different people altogether now I've
never for my part been able to
understand by what justification under
the Charter or otherwise you can hand
over either either by this or that means
one of the half million people who are
different people altogether without
asking them what they think we don't
hand over people these days I hope to
anyone yeah the first thing I've heard
it said in this country that the Briton
exercises a veto over the actions of the
United States and in turn India
exercises a veto over the actions of
Great Britain accurate would you say
that theory is well if I might use mr.
carpenters phrase that's a that's a
slogan which has bandied about a bit
it's quite clear that no nation if it
wants to pursue a course of conduct
which is a respectable African nations
think is limited by any veto and nation
if it wants to can say we'll do this in
respective what other people think but
in these days in the world in which we
live it's a very wise policy to have
regard to the views of other nations not
to condition precisely what the policy
of a nation should be about to have
regard to it in determining that policy
and it's quite impossible to determine
policy without having regard to the
views of other people of the world
Sir Percy president eisenhower's a
proposal for a peacetime atomic pool
seems to be coming along alright
Australia's in on that in it yes we
indicated our acceptance oddly that the
other proposal right in the beginning
Percy it's almost a year since you've
been on this program like to ask you do
feel at the Alliance of the free nations
is as strong as it was during the Korean
War or are the seem showing just a
little bit well I don't doubt as a sir
that in the last 12 months there has
been a substantial shift in the
cloud throughout the world behind the
United Nations of course this struggle
for power goes on primarily because of
the aggressive policy of Soviet Russia
and and the Communist China
and that change in balance of power is
primarily due to the successes the
communists have had particularly in
Indochina and to their psychological
successes for example in preventing
their by well bringing about indirectly
the collapse of EDC and by the progress
which they have made an atomic and
hydrogen weapons and in the result of
course has been a change in the balance
of power I don't mean by that that they
have that they've achieved the balance
of power but there has been a change in
it and therefore renders the the problem
which confronts the free world of
greater urgency well thank you very much
the persons there was a pleasure here
muffin thanks ready here they better be
here the opinions expressed on the
launching Cronus cope were those of the
speakers the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Cronus cope was
Larry looser and Francis W carpenter our
distinguished guest was Sir Percy
spender ambassador from Australia to the
United States the official watch for the
world's heavyweight boxing championship
between Rocky Marciano and Ezzard
Charles is launching the world's most
honored watch in the world of sport the
fact is that launching watches are
official for timing world championships
in all sports and contests associations
the world over including the contest
board of the American Automobile
Association the National aeronautical CA
ssin the American powerboat Association
and many many others now why is this so
the answer is lawn genes great accuracy
and complete dependability the fact is
that in some 75 years of accuracy
competitions at government observatories
lawn gene watches have consistently
maintained a place of honor established
many records won countless prizes and
awards these are but some of the reasons
why lawn gene is deservedly known as the
world's most honored watch the watch of
highest prestige among the finest
watches of the world and why
discriminating people in 100 countries
have found the name lon Jean the first
word in buying a watch the last word in
satisfaction and yet you may buy and own
or proudly give alone Jean watch for as
little as seventy one fifty launching
the world's most honored watch the
world's most honored gift premiere
product of the laun Jean with nor what's
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
this is frank night reminding you that
lone gene and Whitner watches are sold
and serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
launching with noir watches
it's time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour brought to
you every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which noir
watts company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope
Larry Nasser from the CBS television
news staff and Lewis banks an associate
editor of Time magazine our
distinguished guest for this evening is
Stephen a Mitchell chairman of the
Democratic National Committee this is a
time as all good Americans know when the
stores world faster and faster in the
political winds a time when the chairman
of both parties usually declare they can
foresee a trend so we'll ask our guest
tonight mr. Mitchell as chairman of the
Democrats do you really foresee a trend
yes I think so
difficultly as I see two trends one of
them is a I think clearly definable that
favors the Democratic candidates in the
Democratic Party over the Republican
Party but the other one disturbs me and
that I keep hearing of apathy and a
lower registration in some areas than we
should like what do you really think
there is much excitement about this
election and what a low registration
actually hurts you I think that a high
registration helps the Democratic Party
I think the people of this country are
predominantly democratic I believe that
the situation changes in part to some
degree from one place to another and it
isn't it's pretty dangerous to
generalize I think mr. looser
mr. Mitchell what issues do you feel
that have given you this kind of new
strength that everybody is predicting
for you what particular issue anyone
well I think there are a number that we
pretty heavily with people one is of
course the economic issue whether people
feel that they are better or worse off
with the Republicans in power and most
of them are satisfied that they are
worse off or that they are uneasy a
little apprehensive about the future I
believe there is a basic issue as to
whether people feel that they our
country is more or less secure at the
present time than we were in 52 and I
think that they are uneasy again that we
feel that they are less secure there
also has been a growing anxiety on the
part of the many people of modest means
or average means that there has been
favoritism shown by the Republican
Eisenhower administration to special
groups to big business this was
emphasized I believe very decidedly by
the secretary Wilson remarks lately by
the Dickson Yates deal by the tax bill
which favored people who receive
dividends as against those who earn
their money by working and I act during
our buy wages or salaries well now
you've made Dickson Yates pretty much
your own trademark that's regarding the
TVA contracts pretty much by just asking
questions are you ever going to be
prepared to step up and offer testimony
or facts in that case I've been prepared
and I suggest to you I have been very
direct and very positive and explicit in
the statements that I have made and they
have been borne out in every single
instance from the beginning by the
testimony that has been given before the
anti-monopoly subcommittee under a
Republican Senator Langer by the news
that we finally been able to get through
leaks or by the activities of newspaper
men about the various drafts of the
contracts and I of course had
I was ready when chairman Colville asked
me to testify I said of course I'll
testify any time or any place and that
instrumental if you win control of the
Congress in November the that bill what
will happen to it the Atomic Energy
Committee has never signed it hit me
no they finally established they've set
the hearing for November the 4th I was
going to say that they set the hearing
for the end of early in September and
then they advanced it to August and then
they cancelled it now they put it beyond
the election I'm going up to Binghamton
New York and make a speech which is in
the town that chairman Cole lives in
it's in his congressional district on
Saturday night has some more to say
about it but I don't well I think an
answered your question mr. Lew sir I do
not think that Dickson Yates is ever
going to build that plant well you know
here's something I don't understand
senator Fulbright who is certainly a
good loyal Democrat and with a great
deal of integrity has said that this is
a very fine contract and he's quite
happy with it
I think he's misinformed I think that
you should also have in mind that any
one who lives in Arkansas is not unaware
of the fact that there are certain
benefits to Arkansas from having the
proposed plant built in that place but I
I'm sure that Senator Fulbright is
entitled to disagree with most of his
colleagues just as Senator Cooper a
Republican disagrees with the
Republicans
senator Cooper is very anxious to align
himself in opposition to the Dickson
Yates contract mr. Mitchell may I ask
you a question about what you actually
do and now a national chairman
masterminds the a national campaign
because this is these are local
campaigns what else do you do besides
make speeches as national chairman well
it seems that I have a part of the
responsibility for raising the money
which upon which we carry on these
activities of the party the it seems to
me I'm and airplanes are speaking and
good bet at the time it's true but a
large actually large the largest part of
the
work is in maintaining contact with
candidates and with the leaders of the
party and in administrative work in the
National Committee autocovariance
exhibit their money house money coming
in for the Democratic coming in a little
better we're still a long way behind and
we of course will never match the
Republicans but we're doing a little a
little better and we've been very much
heartened by the response that people
have given us lately that brings up a
another point though that shows
illustrates the point I made to you
about the favoritism of the Republican
administration to a big business I got a
letter today that was sent to us by a
Democrat who had been solicited by some
Republicans for a contribution to the
Republican citizens for Eisenhower and
this letter came from Atlanta says that
businessmen are solidly behind our
efforts to keep a congress sympathetic
and more favorable maintain a more
favorable atmosphere for business and in
it they had a little envelope it says
the story in a nutshell and in that they
have a peanut and then they say the
money we are asking from businessmen is
just peanuts compared to what electing a
Republican Congress can mean to business
your business there's the I'd say that's
the in a nutshell is the philosophy of
the Eisenhower Republican administration
what about anything of the people as a
whole and their preference to business
is serve them I think is put them under
suspicion with the electorate generally
what about the popularity of the
President himself mr. Mitchell I think
of that generation to I think it's been
affected I think generally that most of
the people of the country who voted for
him or who didn't vote for him wishing
well they'd like him to succeed they'd
like him to be president of all of the
people it's they sort of identify
themselves and our country's well-being
with having the president get along well
I don't think he's going to make much
difference in this campaign he hasn't so
far and I don't
you will I think you may get hurt he
gets into what a little deeper talking
about the philosophy a moment ago early
in the campaign you disassociated the
Democratic Party from the Americans for
democratic action do you think that
that's given you an extra strong push in
the campaign no I I made it clear as I
think I should and I think that they
would wish to do that there are a
separate organization that they're no
part of the Democratic Party I made it
clear I thought that we're glad to have
their support as that of any group of
loyal Americans for our candidates or
our principles whenever they agree with
them they're not running us and we're
not running them I don't think that made
any difference Mitch Mitchell if you do
will be in our in our activities if you
do win in November what the element of
the party you expect will be in control
the Conservatives or the Liberals well I
don't think you can answer that question
of those those terms at all I think that
the Democratic Party essentially is a
liberal and progressive political
organization I think there's a place in
it for conservatives and indeed there is
a it wouldn't want too much if there
weren't people of differing points of
view look at another way do you think
that a democratic victory would mark an
upsurge in the strength of the old guard
Republicans I do I do and I think that's
that's a very important point I think
that there's a wide misconception that a
Republican victory would somehow help
President Eisenhower actually the
Republicans who are running for office
whose names are on the ballot would say
why this is a mandate for us why see we
this the people like what we're doing
and having more than half of them are
opposing the president well if the
Democrats do win in November are you
people going to be friendly to the
Eisenhower program are you going to be a
hostile to them on the grounds that all
depending on what rawr does Nixon whoa
what part of the program you're talking
about or he proposes great many of the
parts of the Congressional Record
received support of Democratic votes
that couldn't have been an act
without them there are many on which
they were opposed and I think that same
thing will happen again I certainly do
not think that there will be a
disposition to oppose for the sake of
opposition we speaker Rayburn and mr.
mr. senator Johnson made that clear that
we reject the suggestion that there
would be a cold war between the
president and the Congress it takes two
to make a war and we don't propose to
enter into one with the President of the
United States on political matters at
the expense of the American people
surely thank you very much miss Mitchell
Greg that to hear what you had to say
tonight the opinions expressed on the
lawn team Chronos cope were those of the
speakers the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Cronus cope was
Larry Lazar and Louis banks our
distinguished guest was Steven a
Mitchell chairman of the Democratic
National Committee to own alone gene
watches to own one of the finest watches
made anywhere in all the world and yet
unbelievably alone gene watch is not
expensive
there are many outstanding models of
launching watches priced as low as
seventy one fifty the choice of styles
and models is almost unlimited for
ladies lon Jean preached superb examples
of the jewelers are exquisite and taste
and finish perfect for every dress and
for every occasion a firm an laun gene
produces watches for every requirement
watches for dress and for sport lawn
jean automatic watches the most advanced
in the world launching waterproof and
shock resistant watches for rugged
service launching chronograph watches
for sportsmen and scientists and every
launch in watch weather for a lady or
for a gentleman is made to the unique
standards of excellence which have one
for launching ten world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals highest
honors for accuracy in fields of precise
timing and this statement is true
throughout the world the launching watch
on your wrist is not only one of the
finest watches made anywhere in all the
world but equally important is the watch
of highest prestige and unbelievably
you may own or proudly give a long gene
watch for as little as seventy 150 lawn
gene the world's most honored watch the
world's most honored gift premiere
product of the lone gene with nor wats
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene chrono scope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wit nor distinguished
companion for the world honored
launching
this is frank night reminding you that
lawn gene and Whitner watches are sold
and serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
lawn gene wit nor watches
it's time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour brought to
you every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which nor
what's company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Khurana scope
Larry loser of the CBS television news
staff and Auguste texture chief
editorial writer for the New York Herald
Tribune our distinguished guest for this
evening is the honorable sterling coals
representative from new york and
chairman of the Joint Committee on
atomic energy representative coal we're
very eager to talk to you about atomic
energy tonight but I wonder if you'd
mind explaining to us the difference
between the Joint Atomic Energy
Committee of which you are chairman and
the Atomic Energy Commission with the
Commission the atomic Commission is the
agency of the executive branch of
government which has the responsibility
of administering the atomic energy law
the Joint Committee is as the word joint
indicates a committee of the Congress
composed of nine senators and nine
members of the House which is charged by
the law with being constantly informed
with respect to the atomic energy
program and the Joint Committee
considers any revisions in the Atomic
Energy Act and usual one is a
legislative committee the other is an
executive committee and you've had the
full cooperation between you and the and
the Commission it's really been amazing
mr. heck sure the the fine spirit of
cooperation that has existed from the
very beginning between the Commission
and the legislative committee
representative Cola seems that one of
the greatest events to me that you
people have been faced with is the
president's offer to set up a joint pool
of atomic energy for peacetime uses and
I think now that the Russians have made
a counterproposal to President
Eisenhower's offer in which they state
they would that they would desire a
moral ban on the use of atomic weapons
just as there was a moral
ban on the use of poison gas in the last
war now do you think that that is
acceptable well it wasn't exactly a
counterproposal as I understand it mr.
sir
the Russian position has always been
that the nations of the world should
outlaw the use of atomic weapons her
reply to the Eisenhower plan was that
the participants the conferees consider
the outline of atomic weapons now with
that I can find no disagreement that the
conferees give consideration to it
I do hope very however that they their
consideration is not serious nor long
live well didn't they first asked for a
scrapping of atomic weapons and the
scrapping of the means of their
production but now they seem to want a
moral ban on the use of them although
they would be ready as weapons of
retaliation but that was the Russian
counter proposal to the Baroque plan
that the countries the countries having
atomic weapons forego the use of them
but can you see and her counter her
condition of the with respect to the
Eisenhower plan is along the same line
what do you think that could be
acceptable to this country after all
would we be depriving ourselves of the
only weapon in which we are superior to
the Russians that's why I feel our
conferees should give but short to
consideration to the to the suggestion
it would be unthinkable for us to ever
agree not to use the atomic weapon it
might not be a common time and the two
parts of the world were roughly equal in
atomic weapons and then the logic might
be to ban them I don't think that time
need need necessarily ever arise because
it is conceivable that the two countries
Russia and ourselves may have an
offensive potential that would
neutralize the other then the the
advantage would shift to that country
which placed the same degree of emphasis
on the use of atomic energy for a
defensive posture as was used for
offensive in another case the former
head of the Atomic Energy Commission
David Lilienthal has suggested that if
we can't come to any agreement with the
Soviet Union on the Eisenhower proposal
for a joint pool of atomic energy for
peacetime uses then we should go it
along with the
and set up such an agency how do you
feel about that that's exactly the
feeling I have had from the time
President Eisenhower made his
pronouncement but we cannot allow Russia
to successfully upset the Eisenhower
plan it is so essential that the
countries of the world unite and pool
their knowledge in their efforts to
using atomic energy for the good of
mankind that we can't allow any
recalcitrant the belligerent country to
interfere with it because so much good
can come from it isn't it very much like
the Marshall Plan which the Russians
refused to come into and yet were unable
to wreak it's somewhat like the Marshall
Plan except there is the distinction as
I see it we're not giving away to
countries of the world something of
extreme value what we are giving now is
is information in advance to these other
countries we're giving them knowledge
that they all would eventually learn
someday well from a security standpoint
representative Cole could we give away
some of our atomic fuel to a Agency for
joint international use while the
Russians still used their atomic energy
for the making of bombs could we keep up
our lead in the atomic race if we did
that I don't envision that the
Eisenhower plan would measurably
interfere with our stockpile of atomic
weapons and certainly if I thought that
it did jeopardize our national security
I would never favor it but conversely
you would say then that if the eyes now
a plan goes into effect it won't cut
down the amount of atomic weapons in the
world will cut down Russia's atomic
weapon pile either in other words that
problem remains unsolved it will
interfere to some extent with the atomic
potential of whatever country has that
potential but not in a in a great degree
I say the contributions won't be that
large you feel well sir if we did work
out this plan with the Russians wouldn't
we be giving them away greatest some of
the know-how on the industrial use of
atomic energy some of the know-how which
they might not get otherwise assuming
which I think to be the fact that Russia
does not have
the knowledge in the peaceful
constructive productive uses of atomic
energy that we have if the Eisenhower
plan is put into effect and Russia
participates then of course Russia is
going to benefit by it much more than we
will because we Russia has nothing to
give us I think from the standpoint of
using atomic energy for peacetime uses
but wouldn't Russia then be able to take
a peacetime use of peacetime engine so
to speak and put it in a submarine and
make a weapon of war out of it
of course she could just the same as any
other country to whom we might give this
knowledge and allow the use of the
fissionable material but as I see it the
desire for war the need for war becomes
greatly lessened as this great new force
is used for production of things for
which people go to war
representative Cole what is your idea
and how this plan would actually work
would a an international agency set up
factories or plants for the making of
nuclear fuel around the world oh they
actually put up industrial plants to
create electric energy and who would own
those plants that is one of the details
that this conference must work on my my
own thinking is that the International
Organization may either own and operate
the plants or the international
organization may simply supervise the
plants a country which has need for an
atomic power plant would apply to the
International Agency tell them they need
the international agency would consider
conditions and above all it's my thought
that each one of these projects must be
self-sustaining must be self liquidating
must be a profitable enterprise and to
get away from this WPA aspect and
giveaway aspect it must be something
constructive well may I ask you a
pinochle do you think that the
Eisenhower plan would encounter any
opposition in Congress if the Russians
went along with it the plan has so much
in it that appeals to the decency of
people in the world that I just can't
believe that any American or
member of Congress would seriously
protest providing the American people
and the Congress at all times are
assured that this plan will not
interfere with our national security
which nobody wants no nobody expects the
plan to result in jeopardy of our
national security goal if I could just
change the subject
still on atomic energy it was announced
yesterday that we was growing two
divisions from Korea does that have any
relationship to developments in the
atomic field can atomic weapons be a
substitute for manpower in the long run
I think mr. Hatcher that the more we
improve our atomic capacity the greater
versatility we achieve in atomic weapons
the less will become the need for foot
soldiers however I don't think there was
any connection between the decision to
withdraw two divisions from Korea has
any relationship to the use of atomic
weapons may I ask you represented called
if all conditions were favorable towards
the Eisenhower plan its acceptance by
the Russians we worked everything out
how long would it actually take before
such a a program could be worked out for
the beneficial use of atomic energy well
it takes about three years to build an
atomic power plant I expected if the
conferees get together reasonably soon
by summertime or fall formulate their
plans the designs can be worked out by
1955 construction started in the summer
or fall of 55 or so there perhaps within
the next four or five years we can
anticipate an atomic power plant at any
place in the world of the country that
has need for it will be an operation
with these power plants be competitive
with the other types of fuel cold water
power oh yes of course
so that's the that's the goal that we're
all working for is to make them
competitive so that the countries of the
world which have no cold have no water
resources can have nerve
the less have electrical energy to make
the things that the people need as a
final question representative Cole I'd
like to ask you we all are frightened I
think of the atomic bomb may I ask if
you think that the public should have
more information about the the peaceful
uses of atomic energy that's one of the
appealing aspects of the Eisenhower plan
is to start the minds of people thinking
in the direction of how we can use this
for the good of mankind
and the people should know that this
same force can be used for the good of
people to a greater degree than for the
destruction of people already more lives
have been saved by the use of atomic
energy than has ever been destroyed in
the two explosions in Japan the people
don't generally realize that and yet the
field of medicine it's scarcely been
touched in the field of preserving foods
in areas where they don't have electric
ice boxes and so forth
it has great possibilities to say
nothing of generating electricity for
manufacturing goods that people need the
peacetime uses are without limit and the
people should realize that thank you
very much representative Cole for being
here with us tonight the opinions you've
heard our speakers expressed tonight
have been entirely their own the
editorial board for this edition of the
lawns in Corona scope was Larry looser
and August texture our distinguished
guests was the honorable sterling Cole
representative from New York and
chairman of the Joint Committee on
atomic energy why not invest part of
that Christmas bonus in a new lawn gene
watch in the years ahead
you'll be mighty glad that you did
believe me it will be a proud possession
among the world's finest watches lawn
gene alone has won ten world's fair
grand prizes twenty eight gold medals
and so many honors for accuracy the
dependability of your new lawn gene
watch will be a revelation gone will be
the uncertainty about time and every
launching what's your style with good
taste to make a commanding appearance on
the wrist and most important whether you
pay as little as seventy one fifty for a
lawn gene and a gold fill case or
several hundred dollars for one studded
with diamonds it will be made to the
unique lawn gene standard
which made launching in fact the world's
most honored watch the world's most
honored gift and throughout the world no
other name on a watch means so much as
launching the world's most honored watch
premier product of the laun jean wit nor
wats company since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches of the highest
character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene Kranz code a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you on
behalf of long gene the world's most
honored watch and wet nor distinguished
companion to the world honoured long
gene this is frank night reminding you
that long gene and Whitner watches are
sold and serviced from coast to coast by
more than four thousand leading jewelers
who proudly display this emblem agency
for lawn gene wit nor watches
it's time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour brought to
you every Monday Wednesday and Fridays
a presentation of the laun gene which
noir watch company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chroma scope from the CBS
television news staff Larry lesser and
Walter Cronkite our distinguished guests
for this evening is T Coleman Andrews
Commissioner of Internal Revenue
mr. Andrews you've been on this job of
collecting our taxes for a little more
than a year now and you've been pretty
quiet about it before I ask you about
the work you've done so far I'd like to
ask by me just what your qualifications
were for this vitally important post
maybe I should say first a lot of people
don't think I've been so quiet about it
but then event
I'm basically a course of an accountant
management and organization has been my
business for a long time and I've taken
several excursions from practice into
public affairs and addition to that I've
had administrative responsibilities and
the military services and Marine Corps
during the war and I like to think at
least that the president the secretary
employed me because they think that we
did the job as we did in the past pretty
well I hope that's right we also a
Democrat too aren't you sir that's right
a conservative Democrat mr. Commissioner
in this year that you've been in the job
view discovered any evidence that the
American public is indulging and
widespread shirking of their duty and
Bayesian of taxes no are we happened
that I don't think they are as a matter
of fact because we we have a rather
interesting situation in this country we
found that the average American taxpayer
has a pretty high respect for his
government's willing to carry his share
the load of the cost of it and then if
it were not for that then I'm afraid
that we would been in trouble a long
time ago we figure that about 97% of all
the people in this country pay their
taxes voluntarily we call it voluntary
compliance they come up at taxpaying
time and said mr. tax collector is what
I figure my income is and I figure the
taxes so much and here it is that's
mighty healthy thing for the economy of
this country and for the stability of
its tax system just a Commissioner I'm
afraid that most of us feel that the
other fellow is getting away with a
little more than we are now
is there anything against listing every
possible deduction and expense on your
income tax there's not only nothing
against it we want people to do that we
we want every taxpayer to get the
benefit of every deduction that the law
allows him and where there are optional
ways of computing one's tax we want him
to have the way that is least expensive
to him it will take the least amount of
money out of his pocket for instance
take them out of the standard deduction
there may be in most cases a wage earner
will take the standard deduction because
it's simple he doesn't have to worry
about itemizing his deductions but
suppose somebody has a bad spell of
illness journey and his doctor's bill in
hospital bills run up high or maybe
something disastrous occurs to him like
Florida something of that kind or his
house catches fire that sort of person
should sit down and make his deductions
in detail so as to see whether or not
it's to his advantage to take them that
way or to claim the standard deduction
of 10%
whichever waves to his advantage we want
him to take it do you feel that there
are many people in the United States
over paying their taxes by not
completely understanding
cause well there isn't any doubt about
that it's not a matter of feeling there
the argument of people who overpay for
instance in the taxpayer canvas that
we've talked about you've read a lot
about we found a great many people who
had overpaid as well as a lot of course
who hadn't paid an awful who hadn't paid
anything at all and we issue every year
great many refunds to all types of
taxpayers individuals corporations and
partnerships trusts and so on indicating
an excess payment of taxes right as you
lock up house-to-house canvass and you
just mentioned that some newspapers
called that operation snoop called it
Gestapo methods that you went around
asking people at their homes whether or
not they paid their taxes and and
demanded proof that they had and so
forth now one of these fellows actually
do in your campus and what are they
accomplished there well this operation
snoop of course was a little bit of what
I call a journalistic ingenuity of
course if I were a newspaper reporter
I'd be pretty proud of having invented
that one but actually of course that
isn't what it is all of the world we do
is to go from door to door and check on
whether or not the people at each
residence have filed a return it's not a
snoop in any sense there's no barging
into people's homes or anything of that
kind we don't even go in the home unless
we invited and then don't usually go if
a person declines to answer our
questions it doesn't want to answer them
why they don't have to and there's no
hard feelings on anybody's part we don't
get mad at anybody about it and the fact
of the matter is it has been a very
pleasant experience we've had well I
remember in New England in the entire
canvas up there in the first month but
it first came to light that seemed to be
something unusual which it wasn't of
course because the tax laws on that
subject been on the books in his present
form since 1926 we didn't have in a
difficulty there was only one person in
several thousand who even
seem to get be unhappy about it it's not
a snoop it's merely an effort to find
out that everybody is on the tax rolls
who should be on that so that everybody
will pay his fair share of the taxes as
Congress intended and I our reaction or
rather our experience is that the
average person is glad to know that this
examination is being made by us and that
everybody is going to be paying just
like he is I might say that since we
started it or rather since we resumed it
that it's being done elsewhere I know
right now for instance of one state and
one important city we're exactly the
same thing being done on the state level
in the first instance and on a local
level than the other mr. commissioner
what exactly what tax dodge is you
cracking down on are there any
outstanding forms of evasion well of
course the people that that we are
particularly interested in apprehending
on the tax dodging aspect of it are the
people who deliberately set out to evade
the payment of their taxes either by not
filing a return at all or else by
understanding their income or
overstating their deductions and I'm
sure if we had time on this program to
read just some of the cases to let
people see what was happening and we no
doubt about the wisdom and propriety of
what we're doing to catch the evader a
particular segment of the economy where
there is more of Asian than on the other
well I think that question could
probably be answered affirmatively you
usually find of course in the people
engaged in illegal pursuits for instance
they don't want to disclose their income
probably because they're they just don't
operate on the on a legal basis in the
first place and secondly because perhaps
their Fred to the Fed that way then
the illegal activities would become
known and become subject or caught up
with on on their criminal pursuits
how about legitimate mistakes not the
pretty tricky form you make us fill out
mr. commissioner well we don't think
it's tricky I don't want to challenge
you on that too strong because I know
what you're trying to get at I'd like to
get Evert that let me let's let's be
let's get that cat it on a ridgepole for
instance we tried a bunch of high school
students and we find that they make one
twelfth as many errors as the average
taxpayer so if high school students can
make this out I'm pretty sure that the
average adult taxpayer can do it or say
I gotta pay no taxes on that form they
just build out don't feed yourself we
had one classroom racela that 75% of
those kids had to pay taxes and earned
over $600 last mr. Commissioner one of
the main criticisms I've heard against
the income tax laws that they seem to
favor the businessman and not the wage
earner now most of us as salary makers
and we just make our legitimate business
deductions but it seems rather unfair
that the man in business can make more
depreciation that sort of thing
well of course on its face I suppose
that's true but you have to get out to
the bedrock economy or economics of a
question of that kind anything that is
done to simplify the problem of business
in complying with its tax obligation
redounds ultimately to the credit of the
individual why because all taxes that I
know anything about except their state
and gift taxes goes into the cost of
product which the individual has to buy
while he may not he may think that the
business enterprises are getting all the
benefit because that's where the
simplification occurs actually what
happens is that in the final analysis
he's getting an indirect benefit by law
cost of the things he has to buy so it's
not correct to say that because you
change a portion of the law the fixed
bidders that it's unfair to the
individual that's a very short-sighted
in our point what about people will say
in show business where their talents do
tend to depreciate we'll take an actress
who is beauty may be her chief talent
now isn't this rather
you consider this unfairness well I
think that's a very unfortunate
situation but that brings up a rather
interesting question and that is as to
just where do I fit into the tax picture
we are the enforcers of the tax law it's
up to us to collect the taxes that
Congress says shall be levied and
assessed and collected a problem of that
kind as a matter of tax policy Congress
determines tax policy in the final
analysis the administration acting
through the secretary of the Treasury
undersecretary determined who shall pay
what taxes and at what rates
therefore problem that kind even though
it may be distressing is not one that I
have any power to correct it has to be
corrected by high authority and of
course Congress has to accept and a
suggestion on let's go the final
question mr. Andrews what advice could
you give the average wage earner to make
his deduction how can he prove it to the
your collectors well the average wage
earner of course his taxes are withheld
so he doesn't have a particular problem
knowing how much sexy or to pay I think
every person ought to keep a pretty good
record of what they spend so that if at
the end of the year is to their
advantage to claim that deductions in
detail they would do that rather than
claim the ten percent overall deduction
or standard deduction causes save money
that way and say well thank you very
much mr. ku mr. Andrews it's an approved
list to have you here tonight thank you
sir it's been a pleasure to meet the
opinions that you've heard our speakers
expressed tonight have been entirely
their own the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Chronos go
pause Larry lesser and Walter Cronkite
our distinguished guest was T Colvin
Andrews Commissioner of Internal Revenue
a priceless attribute of every lawn gene
watch is pride of possession it brings
to its owner the satisfaction of knowing
that he owns the watch of highest
prestige among the finest watches of all
the world yes alone gene watts brings
more than the delight of a beautiful
possession more than the unsurpassed
timekeeping of a remarkable watch for
that launching watch of yours is the one
and only world's most honored watch only
lawn gene among the finest watches of
the world has won ten world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals highest
honors from government observatories and
a position of preference in sports
aviation and in science for Easter for a
graduation and anniversary a birthday
for any important gift occasion no other
name on a watch means so much as
launching and yet unbelievably you may
buy and own or proudly give a long gene
watch for as little as seventy one fifty
launching the world's most honored watch
the world's most honored gift premiere
product of the lawn gene wit nor wats
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
this is frank night reminding you that
long gene and Whitner watches are sold
and serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
long jean with nor watches
there is only one Atmos the perpetual
motion clock created by la cultura Atmos
runs without winding without electricity
powered only by unfailing daily
variations in the temperature of the air
Atmos product of local for a division of
non jameth nor
it's time for the launch in Cana scope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which noir
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope they are CBS news
correspondents Larry lesser and Walter
Cronkite our distinguished guests for
this evening is T Coleman Andrews
commissioner of Internal Revenue as our
guest tonight would be the first to
admit nobody loves the tax collector but
while the subject of taxes is always in
the realm of politics the job of mr.
Andrews is to see that we pay no more or
no less then we're obliged to do by law
mr. Commissioner since the deadline for
filing income tax returns is still a few
days away do you have any idea of how
many people haven't filed it
well no not not exactly Homma they have
not filed but we've been keeping in
pretty close touch with it from time to
time and of course we won't know until
after the April 15th deadline has passed
for individuals you know corporations
passed on 15th of March well do we all
know until after that April 15th
deadline is passed and we've studied the
results and see what returns are filed
in each week of the filing period just
exactly what the patterns going to be we
do know that a lot of people haven't
filed yet who should have you do know
that yes we do know that but people are
being people as we always are they they
take an advantage of the opportunity
which they was supposed to have to have
another 30 days the only thing is that I
think I should say to all those folks
who haven't filed that these people that
work in the Revenue Service really knock
themselves out dorm
during the filing period and I hope no
one is going to think that I should
insist that those people work overtime
between now and April 15th in order to
take care of people who rather could
file more properly and now rather than
wait until the last minute well has the
extension mr. Andros of the filing
period for another one bit of any help
to the Revenue Service yes it has it's
been it's been of tremendous help to us
as well as the video help to the
taxpayer has helped us in this way you
see we have to keep in mind all time at
all times what our two main problems are
number one is to collect taxes and
number two is to get after those people
who inclined to hold back on us and
those who though they don't hold back in
resorting nevertheless just don't like
to pay taxes or any other pelts
now anything that slows down those two
efforts renders us inefficient so what
we what we've been able to do with this
extended filing period is to keep more
of our people at their regular tasks and
therefore we've been able to hold up
collections and hold up in fact to
increase the number of examinations made
of tax returns and we have to some
extent gotten rid of that peak because I
mean mr. Andrews that more of us are
going to get checked because of this
extra month we've been given it sure
does
you know we've been on a program of
building up our auditing organization
our examiners for well nearly 18 months
now and we expect to go right on up to
the point where we will probably have
about twice as many field auditors as we
had two years ago or 18 months ago and
probably half again more fraud
investigators and we had
that time and I might say that with
improved auditing methods and the
increased force we expect to examine
four times as many returns with twice
the number of people what percentage of
the of the total number of people
putting in returns will get checked
under that and that won't you like to
know that yeah well I'd say let me give
it to you this way what is going to
happen what happens is this a great many
people this returns don't have to be
checked because their income is derived
a tire from withholdings and we know
what that is and we know what taxi owe
then as we get on up the scale the the
probability of being checked increases
in proportion to the presence of a
number of factors which we don't have
time to go into so that I'll say that's
that as we increase our staff are
examining staff and as we improve our
methods the probability of any one not
getting checked is diminishing very
rapidly don't you get to a point where
the cost of the collecting of the taxes
gives a diminishing return for the
amount of taxes collected oh yes there
is a law of diminishing returns but I
don't say this we haven't reached that
point yet and I'm not the am gun to
worry but I will cross that bridge when
we get near it if I may say so mr.
commissioner some people think that the
1954 tax returns are extremely
complicated I think one editorial said
that they were the most complicated in
the whole history of the income tax what
do you think of that criticism well
would you like to me to say what I think
of that particular statement I think
that particular statement was made more
to create effect than it was to show any
evidence of having really studied the
situation and as far as that proposition
generally is concerned though you
probably be interested to know that
actually
there has been relatively little
criticism that the returns are more
difficult than they have been the past
now there's only one good reason for
that and that is that they aren't any
more difficult than the better the past
the exception of two schedules you know
we now have a credit for dividends and
the credit for retirement income well no
one who's criticized those returns has
suggested that we leave those those
calculations off of that return and no
one is suggested in a better way to do
it than we provided those are the only
two things on that return that are
essentially different from last year now
that's form 1040 that deals with the
fellows of fair sized income men and
women the 1040a however which is for the
small tax payer men income up to $5,000
who wants to take the standard deduction
of 10% that's the simplest tax former
income tax form that anybody's ever seen
now that's not just my opinion the
representatives of 85 different
governments of the world of the been
through our shop tell us that it's
really the simplest thing that anybody's
ever developed but the size of a check
made on the card so it can be processed
manually all or by machine either one it
asks certain very simple questions
questions that anybody can answer
contains no calculations we do all the
work so really for about 35 million
people we've made the job a whole lot
easier and we certainly haven't made it
any more difficult for the rest of them
except to the extent that we've had to
provide a means of figuring some of the
credits that Congress in its desire to
give some relief gave them when they
developed the 1954 he said do you ever
try to figure out how much H
Investigator these new men you were
talking about how much each
investigators should bring in in order
to pay for his own salary and expenses
well we don't we don't figure how much
he should bring in we figure how much he
actually does actually what happens
we put a new man on and in the first
year after he has learned his job and
that takes quite a few months to get him
up to that point he'll probably bring in
ten to one the next year he'll get up to
maybe twenty to one and as he goes on he
might even get to the point of of as
much as thirty and forty to one some of
our instance of our top investigators
produce as much as a quarter of a
million dollars of revenue a year and
they only get paid about ten thousand
dollars tops so you see that's twenty
five to one so what they bring in
depends upon how good they are in other
words we don't concentrate we don't say
donated you got to bring in so much
money we say to him you got to be a good
agent if he's a good agent that money
comes as a matter of course you see any
hope of simplifying the amount of
bookkeeping required by those in middle
and higher income brackets particularly
those who are independent contractors so
to speak professional men doctors
lawyers and the radio announcers people
like that to give you a very frank and
suno about to let me explain a little
bit on that the fact of the matter is
that not nearly as many people keep the
records they should as we would like to
see as a matter of fact that's it over
half of the people who should keep some
kind of record don't now then how can
you simplify something for somebody who
isn't already doing what he should be
doing and moreover you can't simplify
the bookkeeping requirements of a Tex
law until you simplify the law itself
but with that 20 dollar cut across the
board have helped your problem any if it
had gone through the Congress it would
have played havoc with us administrative
Lee we would have would throw us into
the worst tailspin we've been and we've
ever been into I don't believe it would
have been ministry it was possible for
us to handle it well since there are
several days left for about two or three
million taxpayers I guess to file their
returns mr. Andrews have you any advice
to give them now yeah I do
have some advice to give them more the
fungal hope please get down there and
get the job over with and don't wait
till the last minute because when that
last minute arrives we just can't get to
everybody that wants to be helped we
have all kinds of facilities for helping
everybody provided they'll come at us
with a reasonable spread of volume and
not all at one time
and we just can't do anything for those
that don't show up on time because after
that is too late
incidentally mr. Anders if a person
asked for an extension on filing their
return this is an invitation for an
investigation no sir not at all thank
you very much mr. Cohen Andrews the
Commissioner of Internal Revenue
thank you very much I'm related to been
hit the opinions expressed on the loan
gene Cronus cope were those of the
speakers the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Cronus cope was
Larry lesser and Walter Cronkite's our
distinguished guest was T Colvin Andrews
Commissioner of Internal Revenue
zone gene has perfected after 20 years
of development what are regarded as the
world's most advanced automatic watches
the exclusive self-winding mechanism is
fabricated with a perfection which
represents a new triumph or non-gm
craftsmanship
now here are facts that you should know
the automatic watch is wound by the
movement of a pendulum or a rotor now
this diagram represents the winding
rotor of many automatic watches see how
it moves in only part two the circle now
this diagram represents the lawn gene
automatic it has a full swing 360 degree
winding rotor every movement of the
wrist produces winding action design
however is only the beginning of the
lawn gene automatic what makes it on
gene what's so superlatively fine is the
unsurpassed perfection of lawn gene
manufacture which has won for lawn gene
10 world's fair grand prizes twenty
eight gold
more honors for accuracy than any other
timepiece if finest quality is your
first consideration then whatever your
needs in a watch whatever the style
whatever the purpose long jean has made
it for you
for every long Jean watch will
demonstrate in full measure the greater
accuracy and complete reliability which
made long Jean the world's most honored
watch the world's most honored gift
premiere product of the loan Jean wit
nor wats company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at this
same time for the long gene chroma scope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored Longy
this is frank night reminding you that
long gene and Whitner watches are sold
and serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
lawn jean with nor watches
it's time for the launching Cronus cope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday
a presentation of the laun gene which
nor what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Cronus cope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. Henry Hazlitt
contributing editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is mr. Tila marcado former assistant
United States Attorney General well
mister chloral now that you are back in
private life and done with being a
bureaucrat perhaps you can tell us
something about the pressures that were
brought on you when you were assistant
attorney general what kind of pressures
are they
well mr. hazard the pressures well I
would say in the third dimension if you
can understand that but they came
largely from the Senators the
congressmen almost continuously from the
prominent men in public life that were
over the hill they come in the form of
telephone calls or visits or what well
the the greater number of communications
of course were over the telephone
but but there were many many conferences
that were had with senators and
congressmen in my office and it's a
sudden they happen to be a little older
and so busy I would accommodate the
German go to his office what would be a
typical request a typical request well
with tax cases for example be involved
oh yes when I was in the tax division
tax case would be involved
one was troubled me a great deal almost
one a very beloved uh when the most
beloved men in America I should had you
love him and I have caught him so many
times that was the vice president when
they called me about an old friend of
his down in Louisville he wanted a favor
from you sir
well sir he was he was uh he was
concerned about the the illness of this
fella and I told him at everybody who
came to see me about tax cases was sick
of something it was sick something some
was wrong with him and I told him that
the doctors and the government doctors
felt that that the ordeal of a trial
were not result in the gentleman's death
in thee there was no other alternative
but to go ahead with your in Pleasant do
do now must order to identify you a
little further for our viewers of course
your this man from your from North
Carolina happily yes Sefolosha and then
for about four years you were in the tax
division of the Department of Justice
that's right you had the say the
authority the prosecutor a tax case or
else to settle it yes sir you and that
that's what brought you on all these
pressures that's right
unfortunately you can't delegate this
power to another unless in your absence
and you really have to stand there and
all this committees got a few and then
the President himself hold off and fired
you didn't he yes sir he was a blue blue
so me I thought that to Manhattan had
reputation of sticking by everybody all
these good friends you were one of his
good friends I sure thought so I tell he
broke the legend though when he will he
will he will he knock me out what makes
what your theory as to why the president
singers you at and gave you the boot
such fashion well I it would take too
long to go into my theory that our
viewers of course know you and one of
these make man
your wife at least got a got out of West
with a mink coat
well she got out of one who was paid for
I was one thinking she paid for it I
have to the last part though I said and
there's a better than bank code have
anything to do with it
I don't much believe it I don't believe
it dead mrs. Truman has a mink coat and
I reckon a mother who has long one for
solo wanted went for so long didn't and
she argued that it will last for 10
years just renovate to be renovated just
once a year that it was all right I told
her it was suddenly getting me the
terminus you bought it what specifically
were you charged with whenever you were
fired well outside activities I've been
trying to find out mr. hue what the
outside activities world is that just me
doing favors for your friends I I don't
know it's one of those things that tells
the President did not tell the Attorney
General mr McGrath
I tried to find out I've been trying to
find out what these outside activities
well well mr. coral you already don't
know at the end of one of the committee
hearings the chairman of a subcommittee
a congressman King a year ago asserted
Jude Ben recreant to your trust and the
done irreparable damage to the
government now what is your comment on
that state yeah he said he said I had I
had done a disservice to my government
and I say to you Mr hazard when when
Chairman Cecil King made that remark he
he did a disservice to his government
and he did a disservice to the Honorable
people that tax division how many I
didn't like it Stephen either I mean it
tax no zoo but in the four years you
were you were in this tax position sir
how many cases would you estimates to
have approximate sixteen thousand civil
cases probably 45% were compromising
settled and approximate 2500 income tax
fraud cases I say now these cases you
I'd like you to tell our viewers you get
calls from members of Congress during
this period very often didn't you oh yes
sir and those members of Congress they
wanted you to favorably consider their
constituents asset
yes so they had a part of the system oh
yes they were they were they were strong
representation had been made to these
gentlemen they were honorable in all of
their relations with me
they were some were very much convinced
that I was about to do an injustice by
indict in someone and of course I will
try to convince a congressman that I had
no other alternate because the fact was
so strong that it just had to be done
I'd like to take up one specific case
let's take the case of the Kansas City
vote frauds now you were in on that for
a while that's why you called in by
anybody or did you step in by yourself
most of the Kansas City investigation
stemmed from a good many calls that we
received in the way of complaints from
individuals out in the congressional
district that congressman Axtell and the
comes from slaughterhouses this was a
1946 yes so that was when I was on
Axtell was the congressman that the
Democratic candidate the President
Truman favored yes and it was it was
argued that fraud was used to elect him
over his Democratic opponent or the case
yes so that was a case of bran a lot of
to do was done about it in Kansas City
or and then it came to your attention is
that well that's right yeah that's right
answer just by way of information how
does a man who's been District Attorney
down in North Carolina how does he get
the position such as you occupied in
Washington some senator bring you there
no so no senator had anything to do with
my going to Washington mr. Clark told me
that when I took over the office as
United States Attorney it had the lowest
rating in the United States and when and
when he wanted one to fill the vacancy
that he had created by accepting the the
attorney generalship of the country he
said that because of the splendid record
which I had made he had talked with the
president and they had decided to extend
the invitation to me and
was why I came to Washington on either
senator who was under too then or
senator Bailey I believe so - Bailey I
neither one of the gentlemen knew about
the invitation to come and of course
they told me he went to see them
personally and after you get into such a
position where you have the decision
over many dollars millions of dollars in
tax cases all of these calls that you
get from the White House from members of
Congress that's inherent in our system
isn't it yes sir it's it is a very very
normal thing that one who has who has to
make the decision he has to face it
that's a soldier dr. Cottle I'd like to
get back to this specific case that we
took up because I think with the clarify
the whole situation if we went into
something like let's say the Kansas City
vote case now you were called in on that
and you stayed in for a while and then
you were taken off it well right no what
happened mr. hazard was that the
preliminary investigation this
preliminary investigation become quite a
famous memoranda memorandum the FBI had
completed its preliminary investigation
in vain embracing all the Kansas City oh
yes sir the Kansas City kid embracing
the investigation the Kansas City Star
yeah they had 50 investigators and there
were 8,000 people interviewed and out of
that number 1354 affidavits were taken
and that was a part of the preliminary
investigation that were reported to me
by the FBI
of course we analyzed these things you
turned it over to the FBI well we asked
them to investigate and we asked them to
- to make a preliminary investigation so
to determine because we knew if we had a
full investigation it would cost a
staggering sum of money because they the
cost almost real and the president
called you off that investigation or go
through his orders that you were called
off or
no no no sir I was Irish see I never
received any communication in the White
House from any source and we all really
believed that the facts were not
sufficient to warrant a further
investigation because we could not find
well that was any evidence that two or
more people conspired together to
deprive someone of a right well
mr. Carter lies one of the important
things to you I believe is that when the
last two or three weeks you've undergone
extensive investigation in Washington by
the shelf committee after which mr. self
more or less rendered this judgment in
which he said that you were a quote an
honest man who was indiscreet in his
associations and a pliant conformer to
the peculiar moral climate of Washington
are now is that a fair description of
your experience a sir
well I know that the Chairman and mr.
Keating was right when they said to the
American people that I was an honest man
I have no disagreement there at all and
I know they're right they spoke of the
peculiar moral climate of Washington you
know peculiar it it is the most peculiar
I think they were right there it was
most pious most peculiar moral climate
you'll find any city in the world
everybody who gets off at Union Station
off a bus or when he parks his car comes
in from the National Airport he goes to
Washington for something and he
disappointed if he does not take it home
with you I say but I'm sure that our
viewers very much appreciated these
frank statements from you tonight sir
and thank you for being with us the
opinions that you've heard our speakers
expressed tonight are entirely their own
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching Crona scope was mr.
William Bradford Huie and mr. Henry
Hazlitt our distinguished guest was mr.
T Lamar Cottle former Assistant United
States Attorney General
a watchmaker such as lon Jean recalls
that Christopher Columbus made his great
voyages before the watch was invented
his only timepiece an hourglass like
this 15th century one which happens to
be the property of the Hayden
Planetarium this of course had to be
reversed every half hour
now Columbus Day marks a milestone for
launching watches too because this gold
medal was presented to launching at the
San Luis Columbian exhibition which
honored the 400th anniversary of
Columbus's discovery of America now
consider how consistently launching
watches have maintained their leadership
over the years lon gene is the only
watch in history to win 10 world's fair
grand prizes twenty eight gold medals
and literally thousands of awards for
accuracy from great government
observatories today's lawn gene watches
are our finest distinguished for
exclusive styling endowed with those
traditional qualities of accuracy and
long life for which lawn gene watches
our world on it truly throughout the
world no other name on a watch means so
much as launching the world's most
honored watch premiere product of the
lawn gene with nor watch company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character we invite you to
join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at the same time for the
long gene Khurana scope a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the
this is frank night reminding you that
on election day you're the most
important person in the country so
exercise your privilege as an American
citizen and vote for the candidate of
your choice
world honored murder
wawk wawk wawk is Bonjean watchers have
won 10 world's fair grand prizes twenty
eight gold medals and more honors for
accuracy than any other timepiece
Bonjean the world's most honored watch
is made and guaranteed by the long gene
with more watch company
it's time for the long gene horoscope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
Norwalk company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching prana scope
mr. max Eastman author poet and editor
and mr. William Bradford Huie editor of
the american mercury our honored guests
evening is tanishka rocky 7 own as the
same general bore leader of the Polish
underground in World War two
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers it'll bore our
chrono stroke audience of course knows
you is one of the great underground
leaders of our generation you are an
expert on underground warfare now sir uh
and you're an immigration Poland now
what brings you to America I was invited
as US keep a date committee to attend
the plus keep a date as guest of honor I
see so you've been you're a guest in
America now for a few weeks
yes and you are now living in London I'm
leaving I've been living in London since
1945 we of course know your story of how
the Europe polish on the ground
opposed Hitler and then how the Russians
a fail to come to your aid that's true
the Russians waited until you were
virtually destroyed wasn't it is it and
is there bitterness now in Poland
against the Russians or is deterrence is
very strong again suppose again the
option is a nowhere the world see we are
anxious to get your opinion sir in
America our people are placing a great
deal of hope and the underground
movements in the satellite countries and
we like your opinions on the nature of
underground warfare against the Russians
now are the Russians more difficult to
oppose with underground methods than the
Germans were or I sink down much more
and wiser young see John the patient
this wall that now we leaking
mr. Lonergan underground movement is
possible and each time I don't see the
underground movement is possible for a
long time in peacetime are the Russians
are more ruthless and dealing with
underground movements and the Germans
were the Germans did not experience of
undergone and see Russians are masters
Russians know more about how to combat
underground was a Novelli low they were
all underground themselves but the side
a lot of Titan underground what about a
underground propaganda what do you think
is the value of our shortwave radio this
voice of American all these it is to get
propaganda into Poland eyes are useless
it's very important it's old the people
listened very carefully to old news
coming from the third free world
whenever you were fighting so
desperately against the German sir where
your people made more hopeful
the radio contact with the rest of the
world or is its only radio system
helpful if you think an underground
movement is impossible in peace
that must mean you're waiting for a war
done
oh yes for the war I think this is how
many more coming yes
how soon is it coming when Z wall start
because I mean I mean how soon do you
expect a war to start it's very
difficult to answer but I don't expect
the law allows it in two years
why first of all I think it's the option
don't want to hit a war now when they
would would like to hit the wall won't
start it to us we as a goal and all are
preparing they of strikes now the body
is ready
why didn't I started two or three years
ago the three are we are the spikes of
the Western powers will improve and the
eruption will have to decide
do you regard our present efforts in
Europe as hopeful sir do you think that
we are building a hopeful counterweight
to Russian power in Western Europe or
yes I think it's very hopeful you think
that it's possible to General Eisenhower
to build an effective army out of the
out of French and Italians before now
sir here in America a great many people
were disillusioned after the second war
they were a great many Americans had
regarded the Russians as allies and so
they were bitterly disappointed at the
betrayals that the Russians seemed to be
guilty are now were you people in in
Poland as bitterly disappointed with the
Russians as we were in America no well
not disappointed we knew of a shrimper
world and say attitude towards Poland
during old jianci Assoc war you must do
known that after they double-crossed
your uprising but you were surprised
when they double-crossed your uprising
weren't you yes
I didn't see that the Russian would
stops here offensive for political
reasons and your as a military man they
had military reasons to come to your
assistance didn't they is true but it
was there also it was waiting and open
for military front of you but it was a
political decision that resulted in your
destruction I think this was only
political decision they wanted the
Germans to destroy him so that they
wouldn't have to after work isn't that
about it oh yes
don't you agree with me that it's about
the worst act of treachery to an ally
and
eglee now sir the state of the of the
Warsaw Uprising and your double-cross by
the Russians that was about November
1944 wasn't it yes and then the the
conference at Yalta was held some four
months later what yes now you people of
course were disappointed at what was
what you call the sellout at Yalta
weren't you I will see this time with a
little law and when we go to news to our
English friends it was a really a blow
boss you you were bitterly disappointed
at the way the Western Allies seem to
have sold out Poland at Yalta yes we saw
what will hit me reforms what is the
position of the Polish army now you have
some intelligence of course in Poland
now haven't you Oh news are coming from
torn very open we know what it involved
and nearly all the officers from Metro
adverbs are Russian in other words if
there is a Polish army now isn't there
his soldiers are boats as really good
pose ISIL as he command he said Russian
command and that was there there
Russians from major on up is your
information wouldn't that be a pretty
weak army to rely on of Stalin Marx
towards the Atlantic I don't think that
this army will be reliable to start he
would hate so ever behind him wouldn't
he yes that that's one of the possible
deterrents of the Russians from starting
a war is
now sir one question Americans have
heard a great deal about the so called
occur teen massacre we were told at
first that the Germans had killed the
great many Polish officers are you
convinced that it was the Russians who
destroyed the Polish officers I was
convinced when I got some news from one
of my men's that I sent the katene in 47
to investigate all in 13 and to bring me
all of the news and all what he had seen
in katene from this time I hit I had no
doubts at all and it was Russian
propaganda to tell us in the Western
world that those poles had been killed
by Germans wasn't it yes do you think it
would be a good thing if the United
States came out firmly and openly for
the overthrow of the Stalin regime in
Russia and in the satellite country oh I
see well you don't want to advise our
government that's the reason I put the
question that way it wouldn't create an
underground movement I suppose but it
would create an underground movement in
people's minds surely yes if people are
resistant all very strongly for
companies but see wait boss you're right
I am a general in America of course we
remember general Pulaski very Khan and
we've always admired the poses great
fighters now in your lifetime do you
expect to return to Poland sir yes I
expect put it down before time sure to
be telling my last book for two people
do you expect to live until Stalin died
oh and what you think will happen man
when Stalin died I think some other
prominent feminists will add it wins
themselves but it's quite indifferent
would be a fight between the communists
at Politburo
but I don't think some secret change in
Russia then general as our audience is
understood you sir
you would like to pose an America to
understand that Poland has been through
many troubles before and if you think
that one day Poland will be free again
thank you very much for being with us
sir the editorial board for this edition
of the launching
Kronus cope was mr. max Eastman and
mister william bradford curie our
distinguished guest was tardos
Komarovsky better known as the famed
general bore leader of the Polish
underground in World War two
you
coaster goes the football season is in
full swing and poster goes to football
games more more than a hundred leading
colleges and universities are time by
long gene the world's most honored
watched in sport yes the games of
Princeton Harvard Dartmouth California
Texas A&M and Georgia Tech and a hundred
more are all time by launching watches
or professional games to our launch in
time all officials of the National
Football League the field judges the
referees and the observers use launch in
what is exclusively for official timing
the reason accuracy not as an empty
claim but accuracy which has been
demonstrated time after time and year
after year in the competitive accuracy
trials at the great government
observatories yes for beauty for greater
accuracy for the promise of a long and
useful life throughout the world no
other name on a watch means so much as
long gene the world's most honored watch
premiere product of the lawn gene with
nor wats company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
character
this is Franklin again inviting you to
join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at the same time for the
long gene Khurana scope a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honoured launching sold and serviced
from coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display the emblem agency for lawn jean
wit nor watches
you